[Música]
saben lo que están viendo en esta imagen
son bacterias y hongos que hace cinco
días estaban en el lugar donde ahora
están ustedes
para poder capturarlos tuve que venir y
desarrollar un protocolo obtenerlos
crecer los y finalmente fotografiarlos
estas imágenes juntos con otras forman
parte de uno de mis proyectos artísticos
en el cual pretendo quedarme con lo
invisible de distintos lugares y quiero
arrancar contándoles porque estos
proyectos son artísticos y no
científicos yo llego al arte gracias a
la ciencia estudié biotecnología acá la
facultad de ciencias bioquímicas y
farmacéuticas donde hoy trabajó como
investigadora de conicet y docente y lo
que me pasó fue que desde mi primer
experimento desde mi primer trabajo en
el laboratorio comencé a disfrutar de
las imágenes que observaba de una manera
especial eso hizo que cada resultado
para mí sea mucho más entonces a medida
que se desarrollaba en mi camino
científico paralelamente empecé a
moverme hacia el campo de lara
en arte mis proyectos de arte hoy
estudio mi entorno cercano y trato de
obtener la mayor información de todo lo
que me rodea y para eso utilizo
metodología científica eso hace por
ejemplo que mi taller en realidad sea un
laboratorio pero los experimentos que
utilizo para realizar estos proyectos
los voy modificando constantemente con
reglas que yo misma defino entonces una
captura en realidad puede ser un baile o
puede ser una acción performática y los
registros si bien pueden ser fotografías
también pueden ser fotos dibujos o
bordados esta constante fusión entre lo
personal y lo científico entre el
objetivo y lo subjetivo hace que los
resultados que yo obtengo ya no
pertenezcan a la ciencia trabajar desde
el arte me otorga mucha libertad a la
ciencia probablemente no le importe las
bacterias que viven en la maceta dónde
está mi mal bond
pero a mí sí me interesa investigar lo
invisible de mi patio y poder
mostrárselos
vivimos rodeados de microorganismos con
ellos compartimos todo estamos inmersos
en un mundo invisible con el que
interaccionamos constantemente tenemos
microorganismos en el aire en el suelo
en nuestra casa en nuestro cuerpo muchas
veces creemos que los micro los
microorganismos son los que nos enferman
y nada más y no estamos rodeados de
ellos nuestro ecosistema funciona
gracias a los microorganismos y nuestro
cuerpo también funciona gracias a
microorganismos en mis proyectos en arte
trato de capturarlos adueñarme de ellos
y reutilizarlos en nuevos proyectos
yo hasta ahora les conté que todo esto
es invisible y porque es invisible si
nosotros queremos ver un único
microorganismo necesitamos de un
microscopio porque porque es tan pequeño
que a simple vista no lo podemos ver
pero en la foto que yo le mostré al
principio o en estas que corresponden a
mi fiesta de cumpleaños del año 2009
estas imágenes no son imágenes
microscópicas son imágenes que tomé con
una cámara fotográfica común entonces
cómo hago para volver visible lo
invisible y poder fotografiarlo para eso
uso placas de petri como esta que traje
acá son unas placas que en la base como
ven en la foto tienen una superficie
gelatinosa con nutrientes se llama medio
de cultivo estas placas están estériles
y si se mantienen cerradas nada pasa en
su interior que estén estériles
significa que no hay nada vivo adentro
de esta placa pero si yo la destapo van
a ingresar parte de los microorganismos
que están en el aire
jpo la plata y los microorganismos dejan
de entrar pero en cada lugar donde se
depositó un microorganismo se va a
iniciar el crecimiento
en horas o en días vamos a tener cúmulos
de millones de microorganismos que si
vamos a ver a simple vista estos cúmulos
se llaman colonias y estas colonias
tienen características como textura y
color que dependen de ese microorganismo
inicial que se depositó en la placa así
puedo obtener microorganismos de la isla
del río
o del patio de mi casa y para esto puede
utilizar el aire puede utilizar la
tierra puede frotar superficies como ven
yo tengo acceso a una gran cantidad de
colores y texturas que inicialmente eran
invisibles obviamente esto hizo que
rápidamente genere nuevos proyectos en
los cuales yo ya manipuló estos
microorganismos en este nuevo proyecto
que les voy a contar lo que hice fue
utilizar a los microorganismos como
pigmentos es decir yo puedo obtener
utilizando técnicas de microbiología
gran cantidad de la colonia amarilla o
de la colonia anaranjada que a mí me
interesa a partir de estos géneros
bocetos que en realidad son protocolos
experimentales en los cuales decido cómo
voy a pintar en mi caso el soporte no va
a ser un papel o un lienzo el soporte va
a ser un medio de cultivo como el que
les mostré en la placa entonces yo
realizo el dibujo
inicialmente ese dibujo es invisible
pero cuando el pigmento comienza a
crecer se ve la imagen que yo finalmente
tengo que registrar fotográficamente
porque porque estas pinturas son
efímeras y mueren cuando se agotan los
nutrientes así surgen imágenes como
estas
en las cuales muchas veces el resultado
es similar al inicial al boceto inicial
que yo diseñé pero en otros es
totalmente distinto porque porque estos
microorganismos crecen y no siempre
crecen como yo quiero entonces esto
constantemente me sorprende
ahora quiero que volvamos a pensar en
las capturas yo les dije que
microorganismos había en todos lados
inclusive en el cuerpo humano y cuando
yo hago una captura en el cuerpo del
cuerpo humano la llamo retrato
en el caso de los retratos la persona
que va a ser retratada puede vestirse
puede posar como quiera yo en estos
retratos me voy a quedar con algo
invisible que en ese momento nadie ve ni
yo por ejemplo
estos son los párpados de mi hermana
y acá pueden ver los retratos de alguno
de los oradores que hoy van a estar acá
en este escenario
ahora
quiero que algunos de ustedes dejaban
retratos antes de la charla algunos de
ustedes deben haber recibido una placa
como esta quiero que las personas que
tengan esta placa se pongan de pie
fíjense que la placa tiene unas cintas
yo quiero que sin abrir la placa retiren
esas cintas que al menos una que les
permita abrir la placa
vamos a ponernos de acuerdo cómo vamos a
proceder cuál va a ser nuestro protocolo
de captura lo que vamos a hacer es
capturar las bacterias que liberamos al
hablar las bacterias de nuestro aliento
entonces es muy importante que la placa
esté cerrada hasta el momento de la
acción porque si no ingresan los
microorganismos del aire entonces vamos
a pensar en una frase
la frase que ustedes quieran no hace
falta que la griten y la dian en voz
alta así que la frase es la que ustedes
quieran
yo les voy a mostrar primero lo que
vamos a hacer es población juntos una
vez que tienen la frase pensada van a
colocar la placa frente a la cara la van
a abrir van a decir las frases que
eligieran no hace falta que el contacto
y luego van a ser rápidamente la plata
entonces ya está la frase pensada
colocamos la placa la abrimos decimos la
frase si la frase es muy corta la
repiten
una vez que terminaron de realizar la
acción van a cerrar la plata
fíjense que las placas tienen un número
cuando termine el bloque de charlas esta
placa se la van a llevar a algún
asistente y con ese número ustedes en
una semana van a poder ver su retrato en
redes sociales y lo van a reconocer por
ese número
[Aplausos]
[Música]
yo realizo estos proyectos porque me
divierte porque me sorprenden porque el
trabajar con información que nadie tiene
y trabajar con cosas invisibles me
otorga un poder que me resulta muy
seductor y también como artista siempre
espero que haya un espectador que
también se sorprenda o un espectador que
comience a interaccionar y a ver a su
entorno de una manera diferente muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]